on y passe des nuits blanches on y passe
des weekends entiers on y passe même
parfois plus que ça c'est bien compliqué
ça nous tient bien eux ce sont des
chasseurs de trésors et ça fait 30 ans
qui sont à la recherche d'un magot
enterré quelque part en France il y a
une notion de défi aussi c'est
intéressant c'est pas un jeu de hasard
c'est réfléchir les chouetteur c'est
comme ça qu'il se surnomme tente
désespérément de trouver la Chouette
d'Or un trésor d'un million de francs a
été enfoui récemment quelque part en
France la chasse a été officiellement
lancée le 15 mai 1993 le trésor c'est
une chouette en bronze cachée dans un
coffre celui ou celle qui la trouvera
gagnera une Chouette d'Or incrustée de
diamant pour aiguiller les joueurs un
livre d'énigmes est publié dès le début
de la chasse 11 énigmes pour trouver ce
trésor cette chouette d'or et d'argent
sertit de pierres précieuses mais alors
qui se cache derrière ce jeu ce sont
deux hommes le premier s'appelle Régis
Hauser c'est un communicant plus connu
sous le pseudo de Max Valentin et pour
sa sécurité il a choisi de garder
l'anonymat dès le départ de cette chasse
on va dire ne montre pas ta tête le mot
la phrase qui a été prononcée c'est
aujourd'hui en égorge une vieille dame
dans la rue pour 100 francs imagine ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour un million bon
et c'est vrai que c'était je me rends
compte maintenant que c'était une bonne
idée puisqu'il y a effectivement j'ai eu
des messages un peu un peu biscornu qui
du style je vais essayer de savoir qui
vous êtes et je vous arracherait les les
solutions énigmes son compère le voici
Michel Becker il est peintre les dessins
dans le livre d'énigme ça vient de lui
il y a dans chaque tableau un certain
nombre d'indices précis dessinés
reconnaissable et puis il y a
effectivement ce que mon imaginaire a
créé malgré moi autour des énigmes de
Max Valentin Max Valentin est mort en
2009 mais malgré son décès le jeu
continue en 2013 le chouetteur Jean-Luc
Jouault traquait le trésor il était
persuadé d'avoir trouvé le Graal à côté
de Poitiers là tu as une rupture dans le
muret ça doit être là voilà
pour vous la chouette et là et non c'est
raté comme tant d'autres aujourd'hui 30
ans après sa création la Chouette d'Or
continue de fasciner les joueurs il
s'agit de la plus longue chasse au
trésor du monde
[Musique]